avant que nous n'abordions le point
principal de notre ordre du jour nous
avons comme comme c'était indiqué sur
l'ordre du jour des
désignations à effectuer ce matin
désignation de représentants de notre
commission à des organismes dont le
mandat est arrivé à expiration à
l'occasion du dernier renouvellement
sénatorial je vous
rappelle que le nombre de désign ant
directement de la Commission a
singulièrement diminué depuis l'adoption
de du de la loi du 3 août
2018 euh il nous appartient néanmoins
aujourd'hui desis un représentant du
Sénat au sein de neuf organismes en
vertu de la loi du 3 août 2018 précité
ces désignations doivent respecter le
principe de parité selon les modalités
définies par un accord conclu entre le
président du Sénat et la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale compte tenu des ce
deux principes et après consultation des
des groupes politiques concernés par les
postes ainsi devenus vacants je vous
propose de désigner Alexandra borquof
Fontain au conseil d'administration de
France Télévision moi-même à celui de
Radio France Catherine belriti au
conseil d'administration de France
méiaamonde Max
Brisson au Conseil supérieur de l'Agence
France Presse Sylvie Robert euh membre
du du centre nationale du cinéma et de
l'image animé elle se Joseph à la
Commission de modernisation de la
diffusion audiovisuelle elle sera
accompagnée de Martin levrier David Ross
au Conseil supérieur des programmes et
enfin Jean ingret au Conseil
d'Orientation Stratégique de l'Institut
français s'il n'y a pas
d'opposition je n'en vois pas il en est
ainsi
décidé et nous allons aborder le point
principal
de notre ordre du jour ce matin à savoir
l'avenir des écoles supérieures d'art il
y a 2 semaines notre rapporteur et
collègue Karine Daniel qui ne devrait
pas tarder je pense euh nous alerter à
l'occasion de la présentation de son
rapport pour avis sur les crédits à la
de la transmission des savoirs et de la
démocratisation de la culture sur les
difficultés financières croissante
rencontré par les écoles supérieures
d'art et singulièrement les les écoles
d'art territorial
difficultés qui entrave bien sûr leur
fonctionnement nous avions eu à
plusieurs reprises l'occasion d'en
parler notamment dans lors des avis
budgétaire je vous rappelle que
l'amendement présenté par la commission
de la culture sur proposition de notre
rapporteur visant à revaloriser de 16
millions d'euros le niveau des
subventions versées par l'État à ces
écoles sera débattu demain en séance
publique lors de l'examen des crédits de
la mission culture afin d'approfondir
notre connaissance de de la situation
des écoles d'art nous accueillons ce
matin d'abord en en en téléconférence
pierre Oudar ancien directeur vous nous
entendez monsieur
Oudard merci ancien directeur général de
l'Institut national supérieur
d'enseignement artistique Marseille
Méditerranée mais surtout auteur d'un
rapport qui a été remis à la ministre la
culture en octobre dernier justement sur
la problématique des des écoles d'art
territoriales et puis d'autre part parmi
nous les deux co-présidents de
l'Association nationale des écoles d'art
et de design public Ulric Bitner
directrice de l'école supérieure d'art
et de design du du Havre rouan et Cédric
Loir professeur à l'École supérieur
d'Art de Clermont
métropole mesdames et messieurs nous
vous remercions bien entendu d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation pour mieux
comprendre les les difficultés et puis
surtout identifier des des des des des
des solutions pour accompagner davantage
les écoles d'art notre commission est
bien entendu très attaché au réseau de
de vos écoles et à la qualité de
l'enseignement qui est dispensé nous
suivons de près depuis plusieurs années
l'évolution de leur situation et les
problématiques qui s'y rattachent aussi
souhaitons-nous que cette audition soit
l'occasion de faire un point au-delà des
problèmes financiers sur les questions
de gouvernance notamment à travers le
statut de PCC et et de vos
établissements et aussi la
question complexe du statut des
enseignants ainsi que leur articulation
avec l'écosystème professionnel et avec
celui de de l'enseignement supérieur je
propose si vous en êtes d'accord de
commencer de donner la parole à à Pierre
Oudard non sans avoir rappelé
préalablement à chacun d'entre vous que
cette audition est capté et diffusée en
direct sur le site du Sénat du Sénat
monsieur oudda je vous propose de
prendre la parole pour débuter fort du
rapport que vous avez produit et des
propositions que vous avez faites vous
donne la
parole merci Monsieur le le président
euh mesdames les sénatrices messieurs
les sénateurs chers collègues de l'ANDA
euh d'abord tout merci euh d'avoir
accepté que je sois ce matin en
téléconférence euh je suis en
convalescence et euh même c'est la
première la première le premier acte
professionnel que je fais depuis
quelques semaines maintenant
euh alors j'ai eu un peu de de
difficulté euh enfin de difficultés
d'hésitation
en sur la manière dont j'allais
articuler mon propos ce matin sachant
que on est dans le on est certainement
dans un des endroits de la République ou
qui connait le mieux le la situation des
écoles territoriales d'art depuis
longtemps alors ce rapport
euh qui m'a été confié la lettre de
mission de ministre parlait d'une
mission flash
elle m'a demandé d'écouter beaucoup ce
que j'ai fait j'ai P à un moment
d'ailleurs euh publier les les les
compte-rendus des entretiens qui sont
très riches et puis j'en ai j'ai opté
pour un autre choix et
euh madame la ministre m'a demandé et
c'est important de le souligner de
travailler à droit constant pour autant
euh aujourd'hui nous sommes nous sommes
au Sénat et alors le Sénat
euh c'est le législateur euh
et pas tout seul mais quand même et donc
je vais quand même autoriser à à à à
dire qu'il faudrait bouger un certain
nombre de choses euh sur le plan
législatif d'abord et réglementaire
ensuite mais très brièvement puisqu'on m
donné très peu de temps alorsfin
suffisamment de temps pour être clair je
je le pense et pouvoir répondre à vos
questions alors
je propose ce matin d'évoquer trois
points qui sont dans le rapport qui sont
d'abord
comment comment on est arrivé là non par
le bout de l'histoire mais je pense
qu'on comprend mieux la
situation si on rappelle
que cette carte des écoles d'art en
France et particulière et là du 18e
siècle
ensuite faire quelques précisions sur
donner quelques précisions sur
l'appareil juridique tel qui est
aujourd'hui et qui m'a semblé un peu de
briqu et de broc et ensuite
euh
et et là c'est la conséquence directe
des entretiens que j'ai eu avec les
collègues avec les syndicats avec
beaucoup
de de de personnalités je m'étais eximé
au à Avignon au mois de juillet euh sur
un état un état provisoire de de mes
réflexions c'est indiquer d'où me semble
venir les sources du malaise qui a saisi
ces écoles euh au-delà des questions de
financement comme vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président alors vous le
savez euh en fait la carte de ces écoles
elle est quasiment stable depuis le 18e
ce qu'on sait moins c'est que les
relations avec l'État euh avec certaines
de ces écoles
euh qui se sont conclus ces relations au
19e donc on est vraiment sur de
l'histoire longue française et
euh la situation actuelle vient d'une
d'une part d'une réforme des années 70
de 1973 qui reste malgré le le passage
au LMD euh le socle l' qu'on dit souvent
enseignement de l'art par l'art c'est le
socle on est donc sur un un système
extrêmement ancien qui n'est pas exemp
de de dogme de doctrine de conservatisme
d'identité et
euh et qui euh a été un peu rafistelé
euh quand on a créé il y a une dizaine
d'années un peu à la vavite je dois dire
des régimes municipales des EPCC à
partir de régim municipal qui existait
depuis fort
longtemps ce qui s'est passé en 2016
avec la loi liberté création
architecture
patrimoine on a voulu consolider
l'édifice juridique notamment en
ajoutant une procédure d'accréditation
euh pour mieux se raccorder avec les
évaluations de du Haut Conseil de
l'enseignement de l'évaluation de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
mais euh à mon avis c'est encore
insatisfaisant et euh comment on est
arrivé là euh et bien
aussi je l'ai constaté quand j'étais au
ministère maintenant je j suis revenu
euh historiquement c'était un service
d'inspection spécifique qui suivait ces
écoles et il a été entièrement supprimé
euh ou presque enfin entièrement euh au
moment de la création des EPCC euh
c'était le moment vous rappelez de la
RGPP et donc les référents au ministère
de l'enseignement supérieur artistique
euh ne sont plus là et il y avait plus
qu'un seul inspecteur pour toutes les
écoles supérieures de
et c'est très insuffisant alors même que
l'appareil
administratif parfois un peu vétilleux
comme a dit la Cour des comptes n'a n'a
pas cché de s'alourdir c'est un des
problèmes de de ces écoles qui sont mal
outillé administrativement pour répondre
à l'ensemble des injonctions qu'on leur
fait alors dans le même temps donc on a
système stable auto stable et dans le
même temps donc on va prendre la
dernière période les 10 dernières
années vous le savez mieux quiconque la
situation le mécano territorial notre
pays n'a cessé d'évoluer et euh avec des
lois importantes sur la sur les périodes
récentes la loi maptable la loi né qui
ont donné des compétences tivité et euh
qui
ont qui auraiit pu faire évoluer les
écoles d'art territoriales mais
euh tout est resté en l'état alors bien
sûr quand on est un système qui ne bouge
pas dans un environnement qui
bouge là commence les frottements les
problèmes et pour les les éléments les
moins solides le risque risque d'être
emporté par le flot si vous m'autorisez
cette métaphore j'ai parlé d'un appareil
juridique qui est de briit de broc il
est lacunaire il est imprécis
euh alors vous le savez ça a été dit
dans plusieurs rapports parlementaires
et et d'autres des rapports de la Cour
des comptes comme me l'ont fait
remarquer de nombreux interlocuteurs ce
ne sont pas les rapports qui manque et
ils sont d'ailleurs tous de grande
qualité
euh le le PCC n'a pas été créé pour les
établissementsenseignement supérieur et
euh
il il et cela fait que ces
établissements oscilent entre la
compétence culture euh des collectivités
qui
relève de la clause de compétence
générale mais euh c'est du volontarisme
de la part des collectivités qui euh là
aussi je je je je vous le savez mieux
que moi euh euh peine à à maintenir les
financements parfois de la culture à
faire les arbitrages et cetera et cetera
et parfois les écoles d'art font les
frais euh de euh ces arbitrage difficile
euh dans les temps économiques qui sont
les nôtres et
euh donc on est entre la compétence
culture la compétence enseignement
supérieur et recherche qui elle-même est
mal définie euh
euh elle est elle est mal définie
euh par la loi maptam enfin
insuffisamment défini et en tout cas
euh n'arrive pas jusqu'à l'enseignement
supérieur
artistique ce qui fait que la
collectivité qui avait été qui a été
désignée comme chef de fil pour
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
c'estd la région très souvent est
absente et les grandes métropoles qui
les métropoles de droit qui devrait être
présent souvent alors parfois le sont
mais souvent ne le sont pas notamment
les trois grandes Lille Lyon
exmseille ne soutiennent pas les EPCC de
leur
territoire alors
et la situation régionale est d'ailleurs
très différente puisque la Région Haute
France est bien présente quand la région
PACA n'y est pas alors euh ce la
conséquence c'est que le le socle
institutionnel de C PCC est mal assuré
et que
euh leur financement en souffre on voit
que les écoles qui fonctionnent le mieux
sont les écoles qui ont été transférées
aux euh intercommunalités sur la
compétence enseignement supérieur et en
sortant de la compétence culture qui
euh qui qui fait que ces établissements
sont arrivent fantasmatiquement en
concurrence avec de petites associations
avec théâtre avec des centres d'art euh
ce n'est pas vraiment
euh comment dire adapté au financement
d' l'établissement d'enseignement
supérieur
donc c'est pour cela je le disais sans
plus attendre je pense que il y a un
travail à faire euh la
ministre euh n'a pas souhaité dans ce
premier rapport
euh que
j'approfondisse ces questions mais j'ai
identifié qu'il faudrait toucher au au
Cole général descit territorial euh sur
les les articles qui qui s'applique à
l'établissement public de coopération
culturelle et environnementale
d'ailleurs vous le
savez le l'établissement public de
coopération environnementale qui a été
créé sur la base de
PCC on voit bien que les les ajustements
législatifs et réglementaires très
légers puisqu'on est sur quelques
article ont permis de d'adapter cet
outil à aux
problématiques du ministère chargé de
l'environnement
euh le il faut modifier le code de
l'éducation pour entre guillemets
corriger les mesures de la loi l cap je
vais pas rentrer dans les détails ce
serait fastidieux mais
euh c'est flou euh quand on cherche les
établissements les EPCC dans la
catégorie établissement d'enseignement
supérieur on les trouve pas et cetera on
peut mieux faire euh surtout 10 ans
après enfin après 5 ans après 8 ans
après euh il faudrait aussi bouger le le
CG3P le code général de la la proprié
personnes publique pour clarifier la
mise à disposition des locaux souvent on
est sur des convention d'occupation
temporaire la
collectivité donne une contribution et
en reprend une grande part pour le loyer
euh la question de mise à
disposition euh des apports en industrie
et en nature n'est pas
réglé la possibilité de bénéficier du
fond de compensation de la TVA n'est pas
réglé il y a tout un boulot à faire euh
excusez-moi pour qu' un boulot mais qui
n'est pas très compliqué à faire faut le
faire euh bon après il y a le morceau du
code de la fonction publique pour faire
évoluer les cadres d'emploi mais là je
pense que mes collègues de l'ENDA
euh rappelleront les revendications euh
des des des enseignantes et des
enseignants euh je dois dire que de mon
point de vue pour avoir dirigé unepcc
assez gros assz gros ça reste petit par
rapport à ex Marseille université
euh cette cette filière euh culturelle
de la fonction publique territoriale moi
me semble complètement délaissé avec des
cadres d'emploi qui sont en voie
d'obsolescence des carrières
plates et peu à peu ça devient de moins
en moins attractif et là je dois dire
qu'on fait face à un blocage qui est
certes financier les les les employeurs
qui sont les
collectivité n'ont pas du tout envie que
le leur contribu tion à la masse
salariale des établissements augmente
mais
euh pour les agents ça devient quand
même très compliqué mais je laisserai
mes collègues de l'ENDA développer ce
point je suis sûr qu'ils vont le faire
pour euh terminer j'en aien ai terminé
bientôt euh on est donc face à une
situation de
malaise qui me semble
euh
lié à euh cette position ambigue et je
dirais multiambigu
euh les cgpcc sont mal positionnés dans
l'univers euh dans la mécanique
territoriale les DGS connaissent mal ces
sujets on les traite comme des
associations c'est mal fichu euh mais
ils sont aussi dans dans une position
ambigue et le la note du
hrs
euh sur l' après
l'évaluation de ces établissements le
dit très clairement euh ces
établissements ne sont pas encore bien
intégré dans l'enseignement dans le
l'écosystème de l'Enseignement supérieur
et de la Recherche on pourrait penser
que ils sont bien intégrés dans
l'écosystème artistique et culturel ce
n'est pas le cas contrairement à
l'architecture par exemple les les
architectes soutiennent les les les
écoles d'architecture vous le savez euh
les artistes
moi je pourrais développer pourquoi mais
ça serait un peu long et puis euh ce qui
produit un climat interne qui est
euh parfois on le sait euh vraiment
délétair avec des des directions qui
partent en cours de mandat ou qui ne
sont pas renouflé ou
qui
malheureusement partent après un
épuisement professionnel mais
l'épuisement professionnel il est pas
seulement lié il est pas seulement pour
les directrices et directeurs il y a
parfois souvent trop souvent d'ailleurs
il y aurait qu'une seule école que ce
serait trop mais malheureusement ce
n'est pas une seule
euh un un sentiment de souffrance au
travail généralisé sur lequel j'alerte
il y a une alerte vraiment de sur la
souffrance au travail dans de trop
nombreux établissements alors il y a
urgence les étudiants d'ailleurs nous le
disent ils nous disent mais nous on s'en
moque on s on s'est inscrit dans des
établissements publics on veut avoir le
même traitement
que nos collègues des université
euh alors je fais quelques propositions
euh
nécessairement complète je pense qu'il
faut à droit constant à minima rouvrir
tous les les statuts des EPCC
euh pour compléter les tours de table
régler la la question des locaux euh
enfin j'ai déjà évoqué tout
ça j'espère
que s'agissant de la DGF l'idéal bien
sûr serait que et quand j'ai rendu le
rapport on parlait pas encore de réforme
de la DGF puisque maintenant c'est le
cas pourrait imaginer que cette question
des écoles supérieur d'Art soit prise en
compte d'une façon ou d'une autre dans
la déchef pourquoi et bien au moment où
le PCC a été créé la masse salariale qui
représente 80% du budget de ces
établissements est sorti du de la masse
salariale des collectivités et en
sortant des des radars du fonctionnement
des collectivités elle est tombée dans
le vide
euh donc ça
euh c'est un des problèmes
principaux et puis ensuite il y a
d'autres petites ou importantes
proposition mais je ne voudrais pas être
plus
long merci monsieuroud quand j'ai
commencé à à travailler sur les finances
locales il y a un peu plus de 30 ans on
parlait déjà d'une réforme de la DGF
donc je je suis pas sûr que ce soit en
revanche vous avez identifié plusieurs
pistes d'évolution législative euh même
si la ministre vous vous a dit que c'est
votre rlection devait être à droit
constant modification du cadre
législatif ne relève pas uniquement du
gouvernement dans notre République donc
nous avons bien entendu un certain
nombre de vos remarques je vais sans
plus tarder donner la la parole aux deux
représentants de de l'ENDA je sais pas
comment vous répartissez il faut appuyer
sur le
bouton non le bouton vert juste en voilà
juste là quelques minutes enfin dizaine
de minutes pour tous les deux et puis
après bien sûr il y a des questions
d'abord de notre rapporteur et ensuite
d'un certain nombre de
sénateurs ok monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs cher
Pierre merci de nous donner la parole
donc quelques éléments juste pour
rappeler ce que c'est landia donc landia
c'est le réseau national des 45 écoles
d'art et de design public national et
territorial c'est un réseau qui réunit
plus que 11000 étudiants c'est un
maillage territorial danse qui offre des
formations en AR en design en lien avec
les histoire des
territoires c'est la possibilité pour un
étudiant partout en France de trouver
l'accès aux études de l'enseignement
supérieur art et design à proximité de
sa ville d'origine c'est un réseau
d'écoes d'accessibles 35 à 40 % des
d'étudiants boursiers c'est une offre de
formation présente sur le sur la
plateforme parcours sup avec un nombre
croissant de candidats depuis 20
ans et en revanche nombre de places
d'enseignement supérieur public qui elle
n'a pas évolué c'est une grande
attractivité au niveau international un
réseau de savoir-faire d'excellence
attractif anda c'est un réseau au cœur
de la filière des arts visuels en lien
avec les associations association
nationale des écoles d'arts
territoriales des pratiques amateures
l'association des classes préparatoires
publiques CPAC c'est un développement
proactif à l'international notamment en
lien avec l'Europe des actions de
professionnalisation un un réseau
d'enseignement en lien avec des
professionnels notamment l'enseignement
transmis par les Pères un programme
aussi de de de solidarité qui permet
d'accueillir notamment
des des artistes en
exil c'est une une rision aussi qui
capable de se transformer donc pierre
l'a rappelé la réforme de 73 les accords
de Bologne les réformes le PCC et les
évaluations
HS c'est un réseau d'école qui intègre
et prend en compte les enjeux contemp
notamment les enjeux de transition et
d'écologie c'est des écoles aussi qui
offrent un accès aux pratiques
artistiques pour tous tous les publics
notamment au travers des cours de
pratique samateur et c'est des diplômes
nationaux évalué par la
churs
bonjour euh alors effectivement comme
comme Pierre Oudard a pu le rappeler
comme euh sans doute déjà un certain
nombre d'entre vous euh le le savent euh
donc l'ENDA effectivement représente à
la fois les écoles nationales et les
écoles territoriales he c'est important
en fait de de rappeler ça parce que ce
sont des écoles qui offrent le même type
de formation et les mêmes diplômes euh
et pour autant euh alors il y a un
certain nombre de points sur lesquels il
y a des différences de traitement et de
situation entre les entre les EPCC des
écoles territoriales et et les écoles
nationales
euh avant enfin avant de vraiment
détailler un peu ces points là peut-être
quand même dire que d'une manière
générale il y a également des problèmes
communs au aux écoles nationales et aux
écoles
territoriales pierre a évoqué la la
question des statuts des PEA donc les
professeurs d'enseignement artistique en
territorial effectivement aujourd'hui
ces statuts sont sont absolument pas
adapté à la réalité des missions qui
sont les leurs puisque entre autres
choses par exemple les les activités de
recherche ne sont non seulement pas
intégré dans leur statut mais mais le en
réalité ce statut ne permet pas aux
enseignants de faire de la recherche ce
que pourtant ils font depuis des années
et et en fait ce ce problème de statut
il est aussi il est aussi commun aux
professeurs des écoles nationales
puisque même si leur statut a été a été
réévalué pour autant il n'intègre pas
l'intégralité des des missions de
recherche et des missions qui sont les
leurs aujourd'hui donc une une chose qui
serait effectivement importante à à
envisager c'est une
refonte une réforme une refonte de ces
de ces deux statuts peut-être pour pour
n'en faire plus qu'un dans la mesure où
nous enseignons dans des établissements
qui euh comme je le disais offrent les
mêmes formations et et les mêmes
diplômes donc ça c'est un c'est un sujet
qui est commun aux écoles nationales et
aux écoles
territoriales un autre sujet qui est
aussi qui est aussi commun et qui touche
là je pense aussi à à euh à la politique
du ministère de de la culture euh et je
crois que c'est aussi un point qui a été
souligné dans le rapport de Pierre
roudard c'est un déficit de visibilité
de nos écoles
euh notamment face à la concurrence du
privé qui est extrêmement féroce en ce
moment en particulier dans les filières
design euh et et aujourd'hui il suffit
il suffit de de se rendre sur un sur un
salon voilà sur un salon des formations
pour voilà les les les candidats et les
candidates qui qui souhaitent qui
souhaitent s'engager dans dans des
études supérieures d'art pour voir que
toutes les écoles du ministère de la
Culture sont sont réunies sur un tout
petit stand alors que les autes autres
groupes privés occupent la majorité de
de de la surface de de de ces stand donc
c'est c'est un voilà c'est c'est une
image he c'est un élément peut-être de
peut-être anecdotique mais qui dit aussi
ce ce déficit de visibilité euh donc
euh on l'a on l'a dit he concernant
maintenant peut-être des des
problématiques qui sont plus spécifiques
aux écoles territoriales euh vous vous
le savez puisqueun un certain nombre
d'amendements ont été déposés euh à
l'Assemblée nationale et aussi au Sénat
la l' année dernière et singulièrement
cette
année suite à la crise que traversaient
les les écoles
territoriales on est aujourd'hui en dans
une situation extrêmement extrêmement
difficile très tendue budgetirement
parlant
puisque on se retrouve dans une
situation où d'une part la contribution
de l'État qui effectivement a été a été
maintenue hein elle n'a pas baissé mais
de fait dans un comp contexte
d'inflation à Euro constant ça
représente sur 10 ans une baisse de 14 %
de la contribution de l'État dans les
EPCC ce qui est quand même considérable
parallèlement et comme ça a aussi été
dit on a un certain nombre de missions
qui sont venus s'ajouter aux missions
préexistantes notamment je pense pour
toutes les fonctions support les les
équipes de direction et les équipes
administratives euh et aussi
pédagogiques qui qui peuvent être
associés à ça puisqu'on est aujourd'hui
en pratiquement en permanence euh dans
des phases d'évaluation donc un dossier
d'évaluation c'est c'est quand même
quelque chose d'assez considérable et
donc ça s'ajoute aux tâches
préexistantes et
effectivement je je j'insiste sur ce
qu'a dit sur ce qu'a dit Pierre Houdard
il y a un certain nombre d'équipes qui
sont en grande souffrance il y a de plus
en plus de difficultés aussi aujourd'hui
tout simplement à recruter des personnes
souhaitant assurer la direction d'une
école supérieure territoriale euh comp
tenu de la situation
euh
donc aujourd'hui en fait ce qu'on
demande effectivement c'est d'une part
un un
réengagement plus fort de l'État dans
dans ces établissements euh donc on on a
on a salué le déblocage des 2 millions
d'euros d'ê d'urgence par par la
ministre de la Culture au printemps
dernier c'était un geste important
compte tenu de de la situation qu'on
traversa maintenant il est clair que
c'est une mesure d'urgence donc c'est
pas une mesure structurelle et c'est
aujourd'hui de ça en fait dont dont les
écoles ont ont grandement besoin donc ça
passe par des financements accrus
notamment pour compenser le
l'augmentation du point d'indice des
fonctionnaires qui aujourd'hui se
retrouve être intégralement à la charge
des collectivités territorial qui
évidemment voit voit les coûts augmentés
sur de nombreux postes hein euh
notamment l'énergie les matières
premières et cetera
euh donc ça c'est une chose ensuite ce
qu'on attend aussi et ça c'est c'est
vraiment aussi quelque chose qui a été
souligné par la délégation des des
présidents et des présidentes de PCC qui
est fortement mobilisé depuis depuis
plus d'un an pour pour la défense de de
ces EPCC et qui réclame vraiment une une
une une meilleure visibilité sur la
stratégie politique du ministère de la
Culture quant à l'enseignement supérieur
culture
VO donc sur cette stratégie politique
que nous attendons donc on on on
aimerait une meilleure cohérence entre
les responsabilités respecties de l'État
et des collectivités territoriales nous
pensons en effet en lien avec le rapport
de Pierre haudard que il faut définir la
répartition entre la masse salariale et
les coups de la
pédagogie aujourd'hui la la masse
salariale dans son fpcc représente 80 %
du budget de fonctionnement et donc on
pense aussi que cette seule distinction
ne serait pas suffire pour déterminer la
part de participation de l'État dans la
marche de
l'établissement je je rappelle aussi ce
que a dit Pierre que nous pensons que
c'est urgent de définir un cadre
législatif pour inscrire les écoles
supérieures d'arts territoriales mais
aussi nationales dont les schémas
régionaux d'enseignement supérieur et
donc en effet nous adhérons à à cette
analyse que le le le fait que les
établissements d'enseignement artistique
apparaî sous le giron de la culture ne
leur permet pas de évoluer correctement
dans le paysage de l'enseignement
supérieur nous pensons aussi que le
cadre légal des EPCC doivent évoluer et
que ce qui est vraiment un problème don
la plupart des EPCC des écoles
supérieures d'art et le fait que les que
les contrib bution des membres
fondateurs n'est pas inscrit dans le
statut et que les les modalités de Réval
révalorisation périodique de ces
contributions n'est pas non plus
déterminé ce qui est dans la situation
actuelle avec l'ensemble des
augmentation des coûts que ça soit des
mesures de révalorisation des points
d'indice mais que ça soit l'augmentation
des coûts de l'énergie ou aussi
l'inflation et ben comme comme a dit
Cédric c'est-à-dire qu'à l'heure
constant la participation de l'État sur
10 ans de PCC a diminué à 14 % là où les
coûts ont augmenté ces dernières années
de façon exponentielle donc euh la
situation financière des établissements
est aujourd'hui extrêmement tendue euh
on pense aussi qu'il y a un point
extrêmement urgent à régler c'est de
rétablir l'égalité républicaine entre
étudiants de donner aux étudiants dans
les écoles supérieures d'art et design
euh l'accès à à une même qualité de vie
étudiante que ça soit au niveau de la
santé que de l'accès à une vie étudiante
équitable
restauration accès aux équipements
sportifs et cetera ce n'est pas
forcément le cas aujourd'hui nous
pensons que l'ensemble des étudiants de
France s'acquitte de la taxe étudiante
de de façon égalitaire mais que les
étudiants dans nos écoles ne bénéficient
pas d'une vie étudiante à la même
hauteur que ceux des universités
notamment euh donc on rappelle aussi à
vaut que la que le que il s'agit de
façon urgente aussi d'harmoniser le
statut des enseignants avec ceux des
écoles nationales mais pas que puisque
on voit aussi que même les écoles
nationales le statut n'est pas en
adéquation tout à fait avec les
universités ce qui fragilise aussi la
compétitivité de nos écoles au niveau
international donc on pense aussi que
c'est'il est urgent aussi d'arriver à
achever les accords la réforme de
Bologne aujourd'hui aussi donc cette
compétition entre établissements au
niveau national il était vraiment urgent
aussi pour nous de pouvoir plus
clairement offrir des parcours doctorau
financé aussi pour les
étudiants l'occasion de revenir à
travers les questions de toute façon
d'horizon merci Karine Daniel notre
rapporteur budget
sur merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues mesdames messieurs alors tout
d'abord merci d'être revenu on avait eu
l'occasion de se croiser en audition et
de travailler ensuite au aux enjeux sur
sur les écoles et j'espère sincèrement
que l'amendement que nous présenterons
demain au nom de la commission sera
adopté par nos collègues ce serait un
signal fort donné aux écoles d'art
territorial et je tiens à vous dire
aussi
que et la presse commence à s'en faire é
la fermeture d'école d'art sur certains
territoires est quand même un signal
désastreux donné dans dans ce domaine et
on y sera très attentif et et et moi je
suis très attentif à ce qu'on tienne un
équilibre on met beaucoup de de budget
et sur une sur un nouvel outil de
politique publique qui est le
passeculture et il faut être vigilant à
ce que l'envie que l'on donne et si ça
fonctionne tant mieux aux jeunes de
s'intéresser aux questions et au sujets
artistiques ne trouve pas de débouché
ensuite sur les territoires en terme de
formation et en terme d'offre culturelle
je pense qu'on aura raté le coche de de
ce point de vue-là et et donc et donc il
faut veiller à ces
équilibres alors Monsieur monsieur
Oudard merci d'abord pour le rapport que
vous avez produit et dans ce rapport
vous écrivez que les écoles territorial
n'ont jamais été vraiment défendu sur le
plan budgétaire au sein de l'appareil
d'État comment comment
expliquez-vous cela et comment est-ce
qu'on peut changer la donne là on cite
singulièrement les les écoles
territoriales par ailleurs vous semblez
dénoncer une certaine
invisibilisation de ces écoles est-ce
qu'on ne gagnerait pas à avoir une
meilleure communication sur la
cartographie des écoles sur leur impact
territorial
pour fortifier ce ce ma et puis lui
donner plus de de visibilité vous avez
parlé de de la question des des des
forum de formation et cetera c'est vrai
que quand on on le voit visuellement
physiquement c'est assez
significatif donc donc on doit ça aussi
considérer ce ce sujet ensuite j'en
viens au rôle des des collectivité
territoriale dans ce paysage avec un
soutien qui peut être hétérogène ça a
été dit euh moi je m'interroge
sur la pertinence du statut de PCC pour
ces écoles d'art est-ce qu'avec le recul
que l'on a maintenant est-ce que c'est
un problème de de statut juridique ou
est-ce que finalement le le statut
juridique n'est pas vraiment le sujet et
ce sont des sujets plus structurels de
positionnement des financeurs potentiel
et et de la gouvernance mais mais euh
parce qu'on peut on peut des fois se
cacher derrière la structure mais c'est
pas forcément le le problème donc
j'aimerais avoir votre avis les uns et
les autres sur ce sujet-là et puis euh
enfin dans quelle mesure la situation
des écoles nationales vous apparaît plus
favorable alors sachant que c'est
toujours une question relative et dans
quelle mesure on pourrait créer de
meilleures synergies entre les écoles
nationales et les écoles territoriales
euh pour donner plus de cohésion et plus
de visibilité global au secteur voilà je
vous remercie de votre
attention merci je je vais vous laisser
répondre à cette première série de
questions monsieur Oudard vous vous avez
bien entendu notamment il y avait deux
questions qui vous concernaient plus
directement suite à votre
rapport sur
euh pourquoi euh pourquoi
euh je vais essayer de faire simple
parce que la la la réponse pourquoi euh
le quand j'étais délégué aux plti c'est
déjà le cas euh le financement de l'État
pour les écoles d'art territorial n'a
pas bougé ben euh il y a eu une
conjonction euh de de facteurs qui est
euh alors qui sont
euh la LOLF auparavant comment ça se
passait il y avait vous rappelez euh
pour les pour euh celles et ceux qui
s'intéressent aux finances publiques
depuis longtemps le titre 4 le titre 6
tout ça était à la Délégation aux Arts
Plastiques il y avait une école en
difficulté le délégué aux arir
plastiques trouvait un peu de sous pour
renflouer c'est un des une des raisons
qui explique pourquoi le financement
entre les écoles est est si disparate et
puis il y avait une commande politique
alors hop on on redonnait de l'argent à
angoulem par exemple au monde de la la
la création de la Cité nationale de de
la bande dessinée bon la LOLF va avec la
création à l'époque du du programme 224
va figer tout ça et euh au sein de de de
l'action budgétaire de la l'action 1 du
programme 224 à l'époque maintenant
c'est
361 et bien cette somme ne va pas bouger
à un moment vous rappelez sur le budget
2013 du ministère de la Culture où les
crédits sont en baisse et comme ce n'est
pas défendu puisque c'est tout d'un coup
entre à l'époque le secrétariat général
et la nouvelle
DGCA qui a d'autres chats à fouettés
euh c'est à mon avis cela qui explique
et puis une mauvaise connaissance du
sujet
euh c'est dit euh je ne sais pas si
madame R est là mais c'est dit dans un
rapport qui a été qui a été rédigé il y
a déjà quelques temps euh dans le suivi
de les mesures de décentralisation de la
Loire rfarin sur les enseignements
artistiques où Madame main de regrettait
et je suis d'accord avec elle si elle me
le permet euh que on est procédé en
plus ai pu j'ai pu en parler aussi avec
Monsieur deasierre on a époque agit en
silo pour le spectacle vivant d'une part
pour les écoles territoriales d'art
d'autre part enfin on n'a pas agi pour
les écoles territoriales d'art et euh il
y aurait à reprendre complètement cet
ensemble sur les enseignements
artistiques dans leur totalité c'est ce
que dit aussi la FNCC par exemple mon
entretien que j'ai eu avec le président
haard de la FNCC il le dit les
conservatoires ça va pas si bien non
plus et euh le financement du nouveau
schéma national le SNOP l'orientation
pédagogique
euh pose aussi problème il y a là un
sujet euh sur les enseignements
artistiques qui sont dans ce pays
décentralisés de fait depuis
euh
depuis le 18e siècle certainement mais
en tout cas disons pour pas remonté au
18e siècle depuis le 19e les
conservatoires euh et euh l'édifice euh
général sur lequel ces enseignements
artistiques reposent aujourd'hui à mon
avis va et il serait temps je le pense
euh de voir comment on sort de cette
logique en silo pour
prendre les questions des enseignements
artistiques d'un point de vue général
parce que pour la collectivité qui
finance j'étais à Marseille et bien euh
on a les la municipalité avait souhaité
fusionner le conservatoire aement
régional avec
le l'école supérieur d'Art et j'ai
dirigé pendant mon 2e mandat j'ai
procédé à la fusion et dirigé les deux
un conservatoire à rement régional ça
coûte beaucoup plus cher qu'une qu'une
école d'art et euh si on prend
l'ensemble des conservatoires par
exemple de la métropole voisine Toulon
Marseille Toulon Provence Méditerranée
si je si j'agrège Toulon à Marseille ça
ne va pas aller euh et bien les
financements qui sont donnés par la
métropole sur le Conservatoire sur les
conservatoires de la métropole excède
très largement les les crédits de tout
façon tout à fait logique d'ailleurs euh
qui sont donné à l'école d'art donc là
encore il y a une question d'arbitrage
au sein des budgets des collectivités
auquel euh arbitrage auquel l'État
pourrait euh que que l'État pourrait
faciliter pardon mais
euh tout est un peu resté en l'état
euh un un
agjornamento général à mon avis sur ce
sujet euh
s'impose monsur pas merci euh peut-être
juste pour rebondir sur euh sur les
questions qui ont été posées euh et vous
répondre sur pourquoi le statut de enfin
la situation des écoles nationales
semble
euh meilleur ou voilà plus plus enviable
que celle des des territoriales euh
alors euh peut-être pour pour
contextualiser un peu ma réponse et et
la relativiser dire quand même que
euh dans les écoles nationales il y a
aussi des problèmes je l'ai évoqué
rapidement tout à l'heure mais le statut
des professeurs d'enseignement des
écoles nationales n'est pas n'est pas
achevé il y a également il faut le dire
aussi euh un recours parfois assez
important à des personnes qui sont
contractuelles donc il y a un risque de
précarisation aussi d'une partie de
d'une partie des personnels euh des
écoles aussi on des écoles nationales
peuvent aussi rencontrer des problèmes
liés à des bâtiments parfois anciens
enfin je pense que vous connaissez
euh la situation qu'a connu et que
connaît encore bourge mais on peut aussi
penser à l'école de Dijon qui est dans
des bâtiments assez anciens euh limoge
sont des bâtiments qui sont plus récents
mais qui ont aussi d'autres problèmes
euh qu'il faut résoudre donc voilà tout
ça ce sont des problèmes qui peuvent
être aussi partagés par des par des
écoles territoriales donc je je veux pas
donner l'impression que la situation des
écoles nationales est absolument est
absolument parfaite hein voilà euh là en
revanche où où effectivement il nous
semble qu'il y a des euh qu'elles sont
dans une situation qui est un peu plus
enviable que la nôtre c'est d'abord
parce que elles ont un interlocuteur
unique qui est le ministère de la
Culture là où les écoles territoriales
sont souvent et c'est peut-être une des
raisons de leur difficultés et de et
parfois de leur invisibilisation à
l'endroit des à l'endroit des politiques
publiques c'est qu'on est un peu pris
entre les responsabilités de différents
ministères donc c'est parfois très long
d'identifier quels sont les bons
interlocuteurs et ça a aussi été très
long d'obtenir un début de dialogue
interministériel on pense que voilà les
choses sont en train de se mettre en
place puisqu'on a l'end été reçu par le
ministère de de la transformation et de
la fonction publique avec le ministère
de la Culture donc les choses avancent
et j'espère qu'elles vont continuer dans
ce sens là
euh mais donc interlocuteur unique donc
ça c'est quand même un quelque chose
d'intéressant malgré tout le statut le
statut des Pen est quand même un peu
meilleur que celui que celui des PEA et
et là où il y a un point vraiment qui
est important urika parlait de la
situation des des étudiants euh euh
voilà les la situation des étudiants et
des étudiants boursiers notamment est
est est meilleure dans dans les écoles
dans les écoles nationales donc voilà ça
c'est quelques quelques éléments de
réponse et peut-être aussi juste une
chose pour là aussi donner un un un
comment un élément
de de réponse plus plus précise et
peut-être plus contextuel euh il a été
très difficile pour ne pas dire
impossible aux écoles territoriales de
d'accéder aux aides d'urgence pendant la
période covid euh là où euh c'était
quelque chose qui était beaucoup mieux
préparé encadré concernant les écoles
nationales
voilà pour compléter ce que vient de
dire Cédric donc c'est sur la question
quel statut serait adéqui ça c'est
vraiment pour nous une vraie question je
pense que Pierre complètera si je me
trompe mais le statut des EPCC donc il y
avait sans doute une comment dire une
une transposition par rapport au statut
qui avait été choisi par par les
équipements pour les équipements
culturels comme les écoles d'arts comme
on a pu le voir étaient à cheval entre à
la fois l'enseignement supérieur et une
mission euh on va dire territoriale
comme quoi c'était des équipements
culturels je pense que c'est aussi une
des raisons peut-être pour laquelle on a
choisi ce statut d'autre part donc il a
fallu assurer l'indépendance des
établissements pour achever la réforme
de de de Bologne donc c'était aussi la
nécessité d'assurer à à à l'école un
une situation d'indépendance par rapport
aux financeurs pour garantir ses
obligations d'enseignement supérieur euh
il faut aussi se rendre compte que que
beaucoup de ces cepcc sont aussi des
cpcc multisites comme peut être le cas
de de de Marseille avec une complexité
territoriale très importante augmentant
euh autant la le nombre d'interlocuteurs
je prends l'exemple de qui est
particulièrement flagrant c'est la
situation de le PCC tout rangé leement
deux régions trois départements trois
métropoles donc ça veut dire que la
direction de cet établissement doit
négocier avec toutes ces à ces
différents instances donc ce qui
augmente vraiment la gestion la gestion
au quotidien de de
l'établissement je je pense que déjà ces
éléments ça illustre assez bien la
complexité dans laquelle les
établissements se trouvent
aujourd'hui merci je vais prendre toutes
vos questions commençons par Max
Brisson merci monsieur le Président
merci pour vos interventions qui nous
font
percer un extraordinaire mystère
français comment peut-on construire une
telle usine à gaz j'ai le sentiment en
vous écoutant en écoutant pierreoudard
et en vous
écoutant que certes il y a eu beaucoup
de réformes
inachevées mais que finalement les
vieilles écoles municipal de dessin sont
encore là dans un monde qui par ailleurs
a a a beaucoup a beaucoup bougé le
monsieur voudard parlait d'organisation
en silo c'est une tradition française
mais en plus ici les silos perdent
beaucoup en ligne et donc les silos
fonctionnent mal parce qu'il y a des
endroits où les silos fonctionnent mais
en plus ici il il disfonctionne moi j'ai
le sentiment comme ça vous écoutez je et
je comprends mieux le le malaise exprimé
dans les deux écoles supérieures d'art
de mon
département je comprends mieux ce
malaise avec un ministère de la Culture
qui vous a toujours considéré comme un
art marginal et
qui ne manifeste pas
propomtitude à vous soutenir un
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
qui vous ignore malgré le processus de
Bologne et des collectivités locales
dont vous avez eu la pudeur de dire
puisquon est au Sénat que leur
engagement éta ta géométrie
variable donc tout ça tout ça cumulé cré
un tableau qui est problématique je
voudrais juste d'abord assurer la
rapporteur nous voterons ce qui nous
concerne l'amendement de la commission
parce qu'il faut envoyer un signal il
faut dire au effort que ce n'est que
cela n'est pas
possible deux éléments d'abord la partie
financière vous avez rappelé que une
dotation en euros constant pe
inflationniste c'est une baisse vous
avez
souligné une curiosité exceptionnelle
alors que tout le monde à l'heure du
quoi qu'il en coûte s'accorde à dire
qu'un effort a été fait en particulier
en direction du monde de des arts de la
culture pour assurer le passage de la
période de la covid que vous ayez été
oublié c'est quand même une une surprise
alors que on peut accorder ici un
satisfa cite au gouvernement avoir
accompagné le monde de l'art et de la
culture
et vous avez montré combien les 2
millions annoncés par la ministre
réactualisé d'ailleurs je crois sur le
PLF était loin d'assurer un rattrapage
alors moi ma question elle est très
simple vous avez parlé monsieur de Mons
de déficit de visibilité moi ma fr
question c'est pourquoi vous êtes au
radar à ce point au radar J compris sur
les aides d'urgence Dieu sait si à peu
près tous les acteurs ont par bénéficié
d'aide d'urgence comme je suis assez
surpris de savoir par exemple vous n'
avez pas parlé que vos étudiants
boursiers ne sont pas exonérés de frais
de scolarité ce qui est quand même
surprenant lorsqueon parle
d'enseignement
supérieur vous répondrez après je la
règle c'est parce que d'autres de mes
collègues vont vont attendre je voudrais
pas les les faire enent donc ça c'est la
partie financière hein qui quand même
pose la
question de cet au radar dans lequel
aujourd'hui vous vous trouvez alors que
vous n'êtes plus je peux en témoigner
comme comme père d'étudiante en son
temps vous n'êtes plus des écoles
municipales de dessert vous avez assumé
pleinement des pédagogies innovantes et
une approche très diversifié de des
pratiques des pratiques artistiques euh
pas en revanche moi je voudrais
m'interroger retourne vers pierre Oudard
la commande ministérielle et je je salue
son rapport et la la qualité de
monsieurar n'est pas en cause mais la
commande ministérielle est à droit
constant il faut quand même qu'ici que
le le sénatise avec force que le droit
constant n'est plus possible qu'il est
nécessaire aujourd'hui de sortir de ce
droit constant qui organise ses silos
malbattis qui pose un certain nombre de
statut vous l'avez très bien dit je je
ne veux pas je ne veux pas le répéter
mais fa sur les EPCC sur les professeurs
sur les étudiants est-ce que vous êtes
dépendant dansun ministère de
l'Enseignement supérieure avec toutes
les règles deenseignement supérieur ou
est-ce que vous restez sous la tutelle
du ministère de de la culture faut poser
ces questions moi je vous interroge
d'ailleurs est-ce que vous ne souhaitez
pas passer sous la tutelle du Ministère
de l'Enseignement Supérieur et de
devenir pleinement des établissements
d'enseignement supérieur ce que vous
êtes de fait hein donc est-ce que la
question ne mérite pas d'être posée on
dire que le Sénat à travers sa
commission n'a pas à dire au ministre à
la ministre qu'il faut légiférer et que
si elle veut pas le faire cher Président
nous pourrions explorer les voix d'une
PPL à défaut d'un PJL c'est également un
peu ce que je laissais entendre tout à
l'heure euh Sonia de la provoté
oui merci beaucoup
euh beaucoup beaucoup de questions ont
été posées de de de choses dites et euh
et bon je pense que en l'état actuel des
choses le rapport qui vient d'être
proposé fait comment dire dé pas un
tableau lucide de de la situation des
écoles d'arts territoriales moi je
voudrais rebondir sur la place
qu'occupent les arts visuels les arts
plastiques dans les politiques publiques
de en matière de culture et sulèrement
dans les orientations ministérielles qui
sont prises de depuis de nombreuses
années sur ce sur ces disciplines euh
parce que en réalité on en parle peu et
c'est souvent la portion congrue des
arbitrages budgétaire euh et et il me
semble que quelque part la situation peu
enviable des écoles d'art euh alors
nationale mieux que territorial et un
peu la conséquence aussi de comment dire
de de cette espèce de de euh de perte de
de de prise en compte de cette dimension
important des arts visuels et des arts
plastiques dans nos politiques publiques
alors vu de la province parce qu'on
parle d'école de province donc on va on
va afficher avec fierté notre province
vu de la province les arts visuels les
arts plastiques c'est beaucoup beaucoup
de présence sur le terrain c'est
beaucoup d'artistes c'est l'éducation
artistique et culturelle euh ce sont des
des festivals de l'animation des
expositions enfin bref c'est euh une
grosse partie du gros des troubles de ce
qu'est la culture dans les territoires
et l'accès à la culture dans les
territoires et c'était d'ailleurs euh
c'était l'objet de de d'une partie du du
rapport sur les nouveaux territoires de
de de la culture euh et vu de Paris
singulièrement tout disparaît tout se
maigrit et on ne voit plus même monde
nouveau euh finalement qu'on croyait euh
l'appelle à projet monde nouveau qu'on
croyait destiner en partie aux arts
visuels ne l'est pas ou ou ou très peu
euh et dans la la la nouvelle action
mieux produire mieux diffusée simplement
10 % des crédits sont destinés aux arts
plastiques aux art visuel donc tout ça
pour remettre en perspective et dire
quelque part qu'est-ce qu'il n'y a pas
un besoin d'avoir une division au
ministère de la Culture qui prend en
compte à l'instar de du rôle qu'on
considère important vu du ministère pour
les arts vivants et bien qu' qu'on
prenne en compte les arts visuels et que
dans cette division là la question des
enseignements tienne toute sa place euh
et donc ça c'est ma ma première question
c'est est-ce que vous sentez Queau
ministère ça existe tout ça cette
question là ce sujet-là et est-ce que
vous n'avez pas le sentiment que
finalement faut d'avoir cette vision et
bien à défaut d'avoir le silo en
l'occurrence chers
collègues on ne prend pas en compte la
la réelle place de de de de César visuel
et de César plastique et puis mon
deuxème ma deuxè question porte
sur sur sur le le financement évidemment
dire que ce que l'amendement de de de
Karine Danel sera soutenu enfin la
commission sera soutenu euh mais euh
dans le financement il y a une telle
différence de financement et
d'accompagnement enfin inéquité euh de
du du d'une école à l'autre que euh euh
est-ce qu'il serait pas nécessaire
au-delà de l'observation et de de cette
espèce de de euh voil de de cet état des
lieux qui a été mis en place il serait
nécessaire d'identifier un certain
nombre de critères et est-ce que ce
travail làà a été commencer en lien avec
vous pour pouvoir avoir euh comment dire
des critères ObjC
de répartition budgétaire et
d'accompagnement de l'État parce que
outre la place territorialisée le rôle
jouer comme moteur ou coacteur des
politiques publiques en matière de
culture dans les
territoires et bien il y a aussi
d'autres critères à mettre en place en
fonction des disciplines et moi pour
avoir une école d'art présente dans mon
territoire je peux dire que elle est
essentielle indispensable et si elle
n'était pas là beaucoup d'actions
culturelles ne se feraient pas et cette
espèce d'âme culturelle dans la ville
n'existe deé pas je vous remercie
président caner
[Musique]
oui monsieur le Président donc moi je
suis concerné par quatre écoles
territoriales dans mon département
d'unkererque tourcoin Cambray et
valencienne et les nouvelles pour
valencienne sont pas bonne du tout
puisque le maire de Valencienne y
compris pour des raisons d'équilibre
budgétaire envisage de réduire
drastiquement les contribution de de la
commune ce qui veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'écoles territoriales sont des
variables d'ajustement des politiques
publies des des collectivités elles-même
variable d'ajustement des moyens
nationaux donc il y a là un jeu de
domino qui fait que peut-être il y aura
des morts sur sur le carreau dans les
années peut-être même dans les mois à
venir donc l'amendement que qu'a porté
Karine Daniel devenu amendement de la
commission dans toutes les
hypothèses risque fort de se fracasser
sur le 493 qui
tombera à l'Assemblée nationale donc
néanmoins faisons notre travail nous
savons que nous travaillons pour rien
mais nous le faisons avec plaisir
euh et en tout cas au moins nous avons
un un rôle un rôle d'interpellation
vis-à-vis des des ministères même si
encore une fois nous savons qu'elle sera
la sanction finale à l'Assemblée
nationale à la fin de ce mois de
décembre euh j'ai bien entendu le propos
de Max Brisson repris par vous président
sur le thème il faut faire évoluer y
compris le droit en la matière mais on
sait que il y aura un délai de latence
pour trouver des solutions durables à
moyen et long terme il y a une urgence
euh la question que je voulais vous
poser président en ayant écouté nos
interlocuteur et je je les remercie euh
c'est une fois que notre amendement sera
évacué d'une manière ou d'une autre par
le gouvernement dans le cadre des
arbitrages que faisons-nous en tant que
commission pour soutenir les 33 écoles
territoriales qui aujourd'hui sont
menacé réellement menacé notamment dans
les secteurs où la situation euh
financière des communes est
particulièrement
fragile pour être clair
entre le satisfait site collectif que
nous aurons demain en votant à priori à
quasi unanimité voir l'unanimité
l'amendement de Karine Daniel devenu
amendement de la commission et
d'éventuelles perspectiv d'évolution
juridique il y a un moment d'urgence
qu'il faut traiter quelle est la place
de la commission pendant ce moment
d'urgence euh colombe
brussell
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président et
merci beaucoup à à vous trois en en
visio comme comme en présentiel
euh
d'abord le rôle de cet amendement demain
il est important parce que en effet
peut-être que son sort dans le processus
d'élaboration et et de non vote par le
Parlement du budget Infiné le fera
disparaître pour autant il a
une vertu principale c'est d'arriver à
poser et à poser de façon étayée chiffré
les besoins les besoins de court terme
auxquels vous avez une nécessité de de
faire face et donc nous nous félicitons
évidemment du travail préparatoire parce
que cet amendement il est aussi le fruit
d'audition préalable de de réflexion
nous avons été plusieurs à à y
participer et et évidemment nous nous
félicitons de de cet amendement que que
nous vot on demain j'avais d'abord merci
pardon pour l'ensemble de de vos propos
très complémentaires moi j'avais trois
questions une générale et deux plus
particulières la question générale et
elle s'adresse à Monsieur
Oudard peut-être n'ai-je pas
suffisamment fait le tour de la presse
mais quel a
été le retour de la la ministre et du
ministère sur le rapport que vous avez
remis parce que j'ai le sentiment mais
je je le dis
peut-être c'est moi qui n'ai pas vu
l'ensemble des informations je n'ai pas
vu de réaction à la remise de votre
rapport et il esttait assez frappant de
voir une situation décrite comme urgente
en terme de besoins immédiat
opérationnel par les écoles d'art des
besoins qui sont relayés par l'ensemble
des des euh des élus et notamment des
des sénateurs et sénatrices et une
absence de réponse du ministère qui ne
paraî pas complètement répondre à à à
cette urgence donc je je serais
intéressée de savoir quel a été le
retour de la ministre et et du ministère
et de savoir sur quelle proposition à
droit constant avec toutes les limites
que ça comporte sur quelle proposition
et conclusion euh vous avez le sentiment
que les choses vont pouvoir avancer et
puis j'ai deux questions plus
particulières on a euh dans le rapport
vous n'en avez pas parlé aujourd'hui
mais dans le rapport il y a un point que
j'ai trouvé extrêmement intéressant
notamment dans dans la période que nous
vivons c'est le le taux d'insertion
professionnelle de vos étudiants qui est
bon enfin de je crois que dans le
rapport monsieur Oudar l'estimait à à 80
% en sortie d'étude
euh finalement dans dans dans un monde
dans lequel la question de l'insertion
socio-professionnelle des étudiants est
une question
euh un chômage des jeunes qui remonte
comment est-ce qu'on valorise finalement
cet aspect-l vous le valorisez
évidemment à l'échelle territorial mais
comment est-ce que ça devient aussi un
des vrais atouts de ce que sont les les
écoles d'art et puis de la même façon et
et peut-être dans la dans la poursuite
de de l'intervention de Sonia de la
provauté euh
je reviens à l'éducation artistique et
culturelle je je ne lâcherai pas ce
cheval de bataille vous en êtes
finalement des acteurs
absolument
fondamentaux cruciaux au cœur de de
cette écosystème et et de cette
pollinisation j'entends tout ce qui est
dit sur la question du rattachement au
ministère de la Culture je je j'aime
aimeris savoir comprendre comment est-ce
que vous pouvez demeurer je crois que
vous l'êtes vraiment peut-être amplifier
votre place dans ce réseau d'éducation
artistique et culturelle et du coup
quels sont les besoins y compris
financiers qui de ce point-là serait
nécessaire pour pouvoir parfaire votre
rôle que je sais être déjà important
merci Jean-Gérard Pomier merci monsieur
le Président pour ma part je suis
concerné comme mon collègue Patrick
canner sur mon territoire par une école
d'art en difficulté celle de tour anger
Lemand monsieur Oudard à la première
rubrique des préconnisations de son
rapport à savoir clarifier l'épineux
problème de financement propose je le
cite d'objectiver l'apport financier de
l'État pour le rendre plus équitable à
cet égard il me semble que la question
se pose d'avoir une règle clair pour le
financement de l'État qui pourrait
pourquoi pas être une aidere forfaitaire
par étudiant en école d'art territorial
aujourd'hui d'après mes informations la
moyenne est de 1960 € par étudiant mais
avec de grandes disparités entre les
écoles car il n'y a pas de règles
certaines certaines écoles touchant
moins de 1000 € par étudiant et je serai
intéressé pour connaître l'avis de nos
invités sur ce
point et enfin Sylvie Robert oui merci
monsieur le Président rapidement mais
j'avais vraiment souhaitais poser une
question à Oudard je le remercie
beaucoup pour pour son rapport il vient
d'ailleurs dans la suite d'un rapport je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez de la
Cour des comptes en décembre 2020 nous
avions déjà c'était la le commission des
finances du Sénat qui avait diligenté ce
ce rapport et nous avions été un certain
nombre à à à être entendu par par le
rapport de la Cour des comptes qui
disait en substance mais très clairement
dans une de ces préconisations que les
écoles d'art manquaient de stratégie
nationale
et que la question de la visibilité la
question forcément de leur
positionnement un peu hybride qui vaut
et et je je trouve assez intéressante le
qualificatif que Max Brisson a employé
ou d'angle mort c'est-à-dire que
personne aujourd'hui ne prend
véritablement la responsabilité des ang
des écoles d'art les col les
collectivités territorial qui qui quand
même finance renvoie au ministère de la
Culture qui dit oui ok mais on finance
pas beaucoup qui renvoie même au
ministre à l'enseignement vous êtes dans
l'angle mort donc c'est un malaise mais
on l'a vu déjà depuis plusieurs années
qui durent et qui à un moment arrive je
pense à à à à ses limites j'avais il y a
quelques années travaillé sur
l'évolution législative des
EPCC je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
c'est Ivan renard qui a été qui est
décédé l'année dernière absolument
d'ailleurs c'était les 20 ans de la loi
EPCC l'année dernière et j'ai eu il y a
4 5 ans j'avais pris l'initiative de
faire évoluer cette loi d'ailleurs elle
est prête c'est une PPL qui peut être
tout à fait mise à contribution de la
Commission et j'avais travaillé avec lui
à
l'époque et j'avais senti que le
ministère de la Culture n'était
absolument
pas pour j'avais bien senti qu'il y
avait une vraie résistance alors moi je
voudrais poser deux questions il y
a-t-il et le ministère de la Culture
a-t-il vraiment
une stratégie nationale pour les écoles
d'art
aujourd'hui après le rapport de la Cour
des comptes après le rapport de Pierre
Houdard après les multiples tentatives
parlementaires de financement
d'interpellation que nous avons depuis
des années et deuxièmement et là je je
rejoins aussi et je trouve ça absolument
incroyable il n'est absolument pas
possible de pouvoir faire
évoluer le le sujet de façon générale à
droit constant il faudra des évolutions
législatives et monsieur le Président je
propose que notre commission au Sénat
s'enare de ce sujet et fasse des
propositions dans les six prochains mois
pour que nous puissions aider les écoles
d'art et qu'on ne se retrouve pas dans
la même position parce que ce sera la
même position en 2025 puisque ça fait
quand même 6 ans qu'on qu'on vit le même
scénario pour convenir qu'àun moment ça
n'est plus possible il y a pas assez
d'argent il y a un problème de
gouvernance il y a un problème de
stratégie et finalement vous l'avez dit
il y a il y a des écoles qui referment
il y a un malaise des étudiants des
enseignants voilà c'est une situation
qui ne peut plus durer et comme l'ont
dit mes collègues et Colom brossell le
la ministre de la Culture a-t-elle enfin
une réponse à tout ce que vous avez
observé
merci merci Président je salue pierre
Oudard qui est l'auteur d'un excellent
rapport présenté devant notre commission
qui a pris soin je tiens à le dire
d'interroger l'ensemble des niveaux de
collectivité territoriale sur ce sujet
qui sont amenés à qui sont déjà
impliqués sont peut-être amenésê plus
impliqués à à l'avenir tout comme je
salue Ulric Hutner avec lequel j'ai
régulièrement des échanges siell ont au
conseil d'administration de l'école
qu'elle dirige finalement mon
intervention va un peu dans le sensou
dans le prolongement de celle de de de
Sylvie
Robert car je pense en effet que de
longues dates et encore maintenant
l'État n'a pas vraiment de stratégie
concernant les enseignements artistiques
en général c'est également vrai pour les
enseignements de la de la musique et que
il est urgent de
relancer le processus de
décentralisation qui permettra que
chaque niveau de collectivité en tout
cas ce qui concerne les écoles d'art se
voit dévolu un rôle précis dans
l'accompagnement d'un secteur qui est à
la fois un secteur culturel mais aussi
de formation et je rappelle que les les
régions il y a quelques années très très
récente avait toute tendance politique
confondu demander le transfert de la
compéten formation
professionnelle je pense que bien
entendu les écoles d'art c'est avant
tout de l'art comme son nom l'indique
mais il y a toute la question de
l'accompagnement de la formation et de
la mobilisation des régions autour de
ces écoles et je pense que s'il y avait
une
clarification tout en laissant bien
entendu à au ministère de la Culture son
rôle régalien en quelque sorte qui est
les programmes au niveau national le
niveau d'exigence et qualification pour
les professeurs cette dimension
culturelle forte je crois qu'on pourrait
peut-être enfin définir une politique
publique pour les écoles d'art le
renseignement l'insertion
professionnelle après au niveau du
territoire ou au niveau hexagonal ou
international d'ailleurs je je je
soulligne à quel point ces écoles d'art
souvent pour 80 % de leurs étudiants
démontre que ceci s'intègre dans dans la
vie professionnelle par la suite mais
voilà je je pense qu'il y a une clé ici
qui mérite d'être étudié je pense que
notre commission euh aurait intérêt
peut-être à à relancer cette question de
la décentralisation et c'est valable
pour bien sûr la musique je rappelle
secteur est toujours en panne et que la
ministre interrogé lors de la loi de
finance l'année dernière a juste répondu
mais il y a 3000 conservatoires
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je fasse
bah justement il y a des choses à faire
je pense voilà
le sens de ma remarque cher
président bien on va vous laisser
répondre peut-être en commençant par
Monsieur Oudar quand même une question
nombreuses questions mais il y en a une
auquelle vous seul pouvez répondre
quelle a été la réponse donnée à votre
rapport
écoutez je crois que je suis le plus mal
placé pour
répondre à cette à cette question aussi
pour pour les raisons personnel qui ont
fait que j'ai dû euh m'absenter et
m'absenter vraiment euh pendant juste
après la la la remise du rapport mais
euh
euh il y a eu peu de réaction dans la
presse si on prend la presse il y a eu
peu de réaction dans la presse est-ce
que parce que dans le rapport je dis que
la presse ne s'intéresse pas aux écoles
sauf aux écoles parisiennes et euh ça a
été dit aussi par euh madame la
sénatrice c'est à la mesure je crois de
l'intérêt qu'on a pour euh en matière de
politique publique pour la question des
arts plastiques des arts visuels euh
pour le design c'est un peu différent
euh et dans la révolution ça a été très
bien dit sur les territoires euh les
écoles supérieures d'art et c'est une
des préoccupations de nos jeunes euh de
plus ça ça m'a frappé quand j'étais à
Marseille de s'impliquer dans la vie de
la cité d'être des actrices et des
acteurs de l'éducation artistique et
culturelle on a ouvert à Marseille un
certificat de formation de plasticienne
et plasticien intervenant
euh qui
euh a du succès on a fait beaucoup de
résidences à partir de l'école
d'art en milieu social et cetera et
cetera ce sont des outils d'éducation
artistique culturelle mais ce cette
mission là elle n'est pas définie elle
n'est pas prise en compte et
malheureusement très souvent elle n'est
pas financée ni pour par l'État
euh par les collectivités si en fait
mais par l'État pas du tout
euh le donc ça c'est vrai qu'on est dans
un contexte général al il faudrait
peut-être passer par par
l'imaginarisme cher à à Stéphane roses
ou en tout cas un peu d'anthropologie
politique euh ça contredit l'école d'art
euh cette vieille histoire du génie
c'est euh euh on on on on on lit encore
je l'ai lu encore dans euh très
récemment bah non mais l'art ça
s'apprend pas et cetera je sais pas si
l'art ça s'apprend pas en revanche
savoir comment euh on est artiste on vit
euh artiste dans la société our euh ça
ça prend ensuite angl mort tout à fait
alors on est l'angle mort de l'angle
mort les arts plastiques sont
cornérisés aujourd'hui après la
disparition de la DAP moi je l'ai vécu
comme délégué au plastique à l'époque
j'étais directeur adjoint de la DGCA
j'étais chef de service c'est bien le
cas aujourd'hui
euh le et là encore sur les territoires
c'est pas du tout le cas c'est c'est au
au niveau central que ça se joue et
euh et euh sur les enseignement
artistique là encore mais madame ma
c'est bien euh que je me suis appuyé sur
son son rapport euh c'est l'ensemble des
enseignements artistiques qui ont fait
les frais
euh de leur décentralisation de
fait il faut chercher patiemment hein
pour retrouver les textes qui
décentralisent euh euh légalement les
enseignements
artistiques et
euh de là à dire que la
priorité éducation artistique qui vient
elle-même historiquement de la priorité
spectacle vivant
euh fait
que enfin les enseignements des arts
plastiques ne sont pas sur le dessus de
la pile des éoccupation du du ministère
il y a pas que qu'on franchit ou pas
mais en tout cas c'est vrai que il y a
un manque de visibilité un manque de
prise en compte et le moi et ça a été
dit par les collègues le secteur privé
lui l'a très bien compris parce qu'il a
une appétence des jeunes pour ses
enseignements
euh la collègue de Ren me disait que
quand elle est arrivée à à Rennes il y
avait une école privé il y en a 20 alors
principalement sur le design alors c'est
aussi
un une conséquence de parcours sup si on
na pas ce qu'on veut pour les parents
qui peuvent payer et bien on va dans une
école privée alors ça accentue
évidemment
euh les inégalités entre les jeunes euh
qui euh on le sait sont sont précaires
dans école précaire avec des enseignants
précaires tout ça n'est pas très joyeux
et euh et vous l'avez dit je suis en
tant que que Pierre roudard ni en tant
en tant qu'ancien
directeur de de de l'inseam l'Institut
marseillais je crois qu'il y a la place
pour non seulement
euh faire évoluer alors à la fin du
rapport je me suis même amusé à modifier
à donner des exemples de modification
des
textes sur le PCC c'est pas très
compliqué me
semble-t-il après je suis sûr
que le les parlementaires et les
services du Parlement seront bien mieux
que moi le faire
ensuite je pense qu'il y aurait un
intérêt à reprendre le sujet par le
biais des enseignement artistique d'un
point de vue général parce que ça a été
dit aussi ça ne va si bien dans les
conservatoires il y a à reprendre ce qui
avait été
tenté dans dans les années il y a
quelques années je va pas sortir donner
la date à la méchappe dans la loi dit
trfarin il y a à reprendre et sans doute
la région et le bon échelon pour
harmoniser harmoniser peut-être pas le
terme mais pour donner du sens
territorial à ces ces
ensembles et
euh j'y insiste
euh bon c'est c'est c'est pas du tout
dans le dans l'a du temps mais ces
écoles supérieures d'art territorial
sont sont parmi un ensemble d'écoles
territoriales dont d'autres sont pas
plomante au sens LMD mais qui vont pas
si mal Bovet est une école qui une école
territoriale
Cala qui avait été diplômante qui ne
l'est plus mais elle fait des choses
très très intéressante
et et en île-de-fance en île-de-fance
quand on regarde l'ensemble des écoles
territoriales d'île-de France elles ne
sont pas diplômantes il y a pas de PCC
diplômant en î de de France mais il y a
des écoles territoriales à viterie à
ivrie dans d'autres départements qui
font aussi euh des classes préparatoires
publiques et qui jouent un rôle
important l'éducation artistique
culturelle donc en fait il faudrait me
semble-t-il faudrait un grand mot
peut-être
pourraiton revoir le paysage en le
redessinant autrement en prenant
l'ensemble des acteur l'arrivée des dnma
de l'éducation
nationale est un fait
qui ne doit pas être vécu je pense par
par les écoles d'art comme une
concurrence moi j'ai la faiblesse de
penser qu'il peut pas y avoir de
concurrence entre établissement public
mais au contraire comme une chance de de
diversifier les formations de de bouger
il faut remettre cet ensemble en
mouvement parce que en l'état il y a
bien l'expression consacrée péril en la
demeure
madame Bitner monsieur
Loir merci beaucoup pour pour toutes ces
questions je vais peut-être essayer de
de répondre parfois en associant enfin
de commencer à répondre en tout cas en
associant certaines d'entre elles il y a
une question qui était liée notamment à
pourquoi pourquoi le pourquoi le
ministère de la Culture et pas le
ministère de l'Enseignement supérieur et
j'aurais tendance ça relié ça à à une
autre question une remarque relative à à
la bonne insertion professionnelle de de
nos étudiants en fait
euh alors
effectivement c'est ce serait pas à nous
de dire à quel ministère on doit ou pas
être être rattaché néanmoins
historiquement il y a je pense un voilà
un attachement des écoles supérieures
d'art au ministère de la Culture parce
que c'est le ministère de l'art et des
artistes et que l'enseignement dans les
écoles supérieurs d'Art et Design
qu'elle soit d'ailleurs territoriale ou
nationale ça ça n'est ça n'a absolument
aucune importance là-dedans c'est
l'enseignement par les paères et c'est
l'enseignement de l'art par l'art et
même si on sait que tous nos diplômés ne
deviennent pas artistes de
carrière je suis
convaincu que le succès de leur
insertion professionnelle n'est pas
seulement dû au module plus spécifique
que l'on peut faire parce qu'évid on
prépare les
étudiants à leur vie professionnelle sur
des choses parfois très concrètes de
droit de comment comment on s'installe
comme travailleurs indépendant et cetera
et cetera mais mais mais en fait la
cette professionnalisation enfin cette
cette insertion professionnelle pardon
elle est liée au fait que l'enseignement
de l'art se fait par et avec des
artistes et par les méthodes de l'art et
ça c'est vraiment une dimension qui est
fondamentale et c'est une manière de
dire aussi que les écoles d'art c'est
pas c'est pas simplement une manière
d'entrer ou d'accéder au monde de l'art
en fait les écoles d'art c'est déjà le
monde de l'art en fait il y a pas une
séparation entre les deux c'est les
écoles d'art sont un employeur
extrêmement important du du secteur
artistique en fait beaucoup
d'artistes travaillent de manière
permanente ou ou de manière régulière
dans dans les écoles d'art donc ça c'est
un c'est c'est un c'est un point qui me
semble vraiment vraiment important et
donc ça voilà il y a une sorte de
logique presque organique quià être
rattaché au ministère de la Culture même
si bien sûr aujourd'hui on a évolué il y
a aussi les associations des
partenariats avec l'enseignement
supérieur et les universités donc c'est
une part évidemment aussi importante à à
prendre en compte et puis euh euh une
une chose aussi euh euh vous vous avez
rappelé que euh euh comment dire que
parfois ce qui se passait dans dans dans
les dans les écoles en région était
difficile ement visible depuis Paris bon
ça je pense que c'est une vieille
histoire française d'une manière ça
excède les écoles d'art mais peut-être
rappeler très brièvement parce que je
sais que Pierre Oudard est plutôt
spécialiste du sujet donc je je voudrais
pas m'avancer trop loin mais
effectivement vous avez évoqué un moment
le
le le fait que les écoles municipales
avaient l'air de toujours exister alors
c'est vrai que beaucoup de beaucoup
d'écoles d'art aujourd'hui sont été à
l'origine des écoles avec une dimension
municipal alors soit parce qu'elles
avaient été voulues par par des édites
locaux ou ou le plus souvent en fait
parce qu'il y avait un lien avec une
activité économique locale en fait
parfois industrielle aussi donc les
beaucoup d'écoles de dessin ont été ont
été fondé de de cette façon-là et euh et
et
donc aujourd'hui en fait on on on
pourrait se dire aussi que d'une
certaine manière cette enfin cet
héritage là il il est renouvelé parce
que si on si on parle beaucoup des
écoles comme étant des charges hein que
ce soit des charges pour l'État charges
pour les collectivités en fait c'est
aussi des endroits qui produisent de la
richesse justement avec cette insertion
professionnels des étudiants euh on on
pense aujourd'hui déjà dans les dans les
pédagogies en fait euh à au monde avenir
euh les écoles elles sont déjà depuis
plusieurs années euh en chemin sur euh
pour pour mettre en œuvre une meilleure
inclusion euh une meilleure inclusivité
pardon de euh des étudiants et des
étudiantes à travers euh leur multitude
de parcours d'identité et cetera euh
elles sont aussi déjà actives sur tous
les sujets liés aux transitions
écologique euh aux réflexions sur les
nouvelles ruralités et cetera donc tous
ces sujets-là en fait c'est aussi des
enfin voilà c'est des sujets qui qui
débordent très largement le le le le le
petit périmètre de l'art et et des et
des artistes qui sont visibles sur le
marché international voyez donc c'est à
cet endroit-là je pense aussi que les
les écoles d'art produisent de la valeur
oui peut-être rappeler aussi que onia à
nouveau he parce que nous sommes là pour
représenter l'association que nous avons
tenu notre séminaire annuel il y a peu
et que lors de ce séminaire nous avons
présenter en fait un ensemble de travaux
que les écoles font euh partout sur le
territoire que ce soit dans les
applications de l'art en lien avec
l'espace public que soit des travaux en
lien avec la ruralité et citons à cet
exemple par exemple le le le le
postmas euh les mondes rurau à non Tron
dans le pigor que ce soit aussi des
questions de lien entre l'art et les
pratiques dans la dans le domaine de la
santé donc vous voyez c'est pour vous
dire à quel point les écoles aussi sont
soucieuses pour penser leur lien avec le
monde en mouvement et le monde en et
aussi le monde àenir Je je voulais
revenir sur sur la question de la
filière qui est apparue et moi je je
pense que enfin en tout cas à titre
personnel je suis entièrement d'accord
avec cette lecture on voit bien que
l'école supérieure d'art dans son
territoire souvent est compris he par
historiquement comme l'école des
beauards les gens la connaissent et
cetera les gens se réfèent à son
histoire et cetera on voit aussi que
l'État au travers des sodav notamment a
voulu interroger dans chaque région quel
était l'état du réseau l'État de la
filière et on voit que euh cette analyse
qui pour certaines régions a donné lieu
à des associations euh comme ça peut
être le cas euh euh au pied de la Loire
le réseau des arts visuels comme c'est
le cas en région Centre par devenir art
ou encore en Normandie RN13 bis qui
préexistit on voit qu'il y a là matière
à à organiser l'ensemble de la filière
euh que ça soit la diffusion
l'enseignement et quand on dit
l'enseignement dans tout ces composants
l'enseignement des pratiques amateures
l'enseignement initial supérieur
l'enseignement professionnel et
l'enseignement à tous les moments de la
vie voilà donc je pense que il y a là
une une réflexion de fond qui qui doit
être menée de façon à ce que les AR
visuel ne soit pas le le parent pauvre
des politiques publiques culturelles que
l'enseignement supérieur d'Art aussi ne
soit pas justement un enseignement
pauvre de de l'enseignement supérieur
français
euh donc c'est ça c'est vraiment des des
et je pense que en tout cas pour ce qui
est les associations professionnelles
qui œuvrent dans ce champ une prise de
conscience très aigu actuellement de la
nécessité de mener ces travaux de façon
concertée entre dans toutes les
composantes qui qui concerné par par
l'enseignement je voulais revenir quand
même un peu aussi sur la situation des
des enseignants pour vous illustrer
peut-être assez concrètement la
difficulté qui ont les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur en particulier
territorial à de de à répondre de
manière efficiente en fait au au
nouvelles exigences euh qui qui qui nous
incombent et donc je je vous rappelle
euh un décret de 2023 qui oblige tous
les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur de prendre en charge l'accès à
un service de santé pour leurs étudiants
donc voyez c'est assez concret euh donc
et je voulais aussi par un autre décret
vous rappeler celui d'un décret de 2018
qui concerne la redistribution des de de
la contribution à la vie étudiante la
sévec et et et de vous dire aussi que ce
décret B en fait il il il donne il il
redistribue moitié moins aux écoles
supérieures d'art que aux universités
par exemple ce qui voyez ce qui nous EMP
put don les obligations qui nous incombe
de répondre à bah à la qualité de la vie
étudiante tout simplement donc je pense
qu'il y a là c'est des petits points
assez précis mais qui illustrent je
pense de façon assez flagrante quoi le
le la la problématique auquelle auquel
nous
faisons
référence et et et oui et je pense aussi
que cette aussi cette cette filière des
arts visuels elle est vraiment aussi au
cœur de la professionnalisation c'est
vrai que le rapport de la Cour de
comptes de 2020 reproche aux écoles
supérieures d'art ça manque de stratégie
ça manque de de d'insertion
professionnelle le le faible niveau de
revenu des étudiants diplômés mais c'est
sans prendre en compte aussi le fait que
le le l'établissement d'enseignement
supérieur est le premier employeur des
artistes de son territoire que
l'ensemble de ces activités
d'enseignement auxquel nous faisons tous
référence est aussi une issue de
professionnalisation pour les étudiants
et je pense qu'aussi il est grand temps
de penser l'école supérieure d'art non
pas comme un endroit où on forme
exclusive ement des artistes mais un
endroit où on forme des professionnels
pour des usages de l'art et du design
partout dans la société à différentes
échelles donc je pense que c'est
vraiment important de que et Pierre l'a
dit aussi de sortir de l'idée de de
jeunie artistique solitaire si vous
voulez qui qui a pu être un modèle de
des écoles par le passé et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la réalité d'une école
supériorda n'est pas du tout celle-là
donc je peut-être je je voulais M dessus
et aussi vous dire que bon on a parlé de
l'école de Valencienne mais nous savons
aussi depuis peu que il y a une nouvelle
école qui est mise en difficulté c'est
l'école de Chalon
donc aussi nous Rapp enfin vous rappelez
tous que en fait cette situation elle
est elle est elle est vraiment précise
on je sais aussi enfin nous savons au
sein d'andia que plusieurs écoles même
des gros établissements sont en
difficultés seront en difficulté
concrètes pour boucler leur leur budget
dès
2024 je pense que Monsieur peut-être au
niveau aussi je sais que ça peut être le
cas par exemple de tourangé lement où la
situation est assez est très tendue je
sais que c'est le cas en Bretagne
également et que bah voilà on est quand
même dans sa situation de d'urgence et
je pense que oui voilà il y a plusieurs
temporalités c'est comment comment tenir
dans ce premier temps et puis après
[Musique]
commentform met en profondeur un système
voilà mais c'est voilà et comme disait
je sais pas qui d'entre vous voilà il y
a ces deux temporalités donc il faut
quand même
trouver aussi
comment progresser actuellement
oui merci c'est c'est c'est vraiment
très bref effectivement je je pense
qu'on pouvait on ne pouvait pas enfin
être reçu ici et ne pas et ne pas
évoquer ou réévo équ le cas de l'école
d'art de Valencienne et maintenant de
l'école de
Chalon qui effectivement sont dans des
processus de de de
fermeture sans doute très rapide et là
on voit bien alors à la fois la très
relative indépendance des EPCC puisque
comme elles sont financées à très grande
majorité par une collectivité
territoriale ben il est clair que quand
cette collectivité retire tout ou partie
de ses
financements évidemment on peut on peut
difficilement demander à l'État de
compenser la totalité hein c'est pas du
tout le sujet euh en revanche enfin je
fais le lien avec avec ce que vous
évoquez hein l'angle mort euh je pense
que pour ces écoles
euh en fait elles pâtissent aussi de
cette situation d'angle mort parce que
généralement en fait quand on se rend
compte qu'une école va si mal ou ou ou
qu'elle qu'elle est sur le point de
fermer euh c'est parce qu'on n'a pas vu
les signes avant couroureur ou parce
qu'il ils sont pas remontés suffisamment
vite donc ce qu'on attend nous en tant
que R réseau he on essaie évidemment
comme comme on peut de de de faire
évoluer la situation différemment euh je
sais que les organisations syndicales le
font aussi que il y a pas mal de
discussions aussi en en région pour que
ça puisse peut-être proposer un autre
scénario mais je pense que ce qui est
important à cet endroit-là aussi c'est
que le ministère de la Culture exerce
pleinement cette hutelle et qui
défendent ses formations et ses diplômes
et c'est pas uniquement une question
d'argent voilà
merci merci au aux autres mer monsieur
Boudda et et merci aux deux
co-présidents de de l'ENDA je crois que
cette table ronde était importante é
importante notamment dans le cadre du
processus budgétaire qui est le nôtre
actuellement avec l'amendement qui sera
présenté demain qui a déjà eu le large
soutien de la Commission mais il faut
faire en sorte bien sûr qu'il est qu'il
est également large soutien du du Sénat
il appartiendra à l'état de de prendre
sa décision finale en tout cas ce sera
l'occasion d'avoir une discussion avec
la ministre et euh vu vos interventions
respectives je ne doute pas que nous
serons un certain nombre à l'interroger
demain dans le cadre du du débat
budgétaire et espérons avoir des
réponses pour pour la suite de
notre de notre réflexion qui est plus
une réflexion mais de notre intérêt pour
les écoles d'art et de notre
responsabilité dans l'accompagnement que
que que les responsables publics vous
vous doiv pas trancher là maintenant on
réunira le bureau la semaine prochaine
comme je vous l'avais annoncé pour
définir le le programme du travail mais
je crois que le fait d'avoir tenu cette
table ronde ce matin est un élément
important justement pour préparer nos
nos décisions de la semaine prochaine
voilà merci beaucoup merci beaucoup de
nous avoir reçu et merci pour cet
amendement oui merci beaucoup au revoir
merci